[Music]
why every I no matter how hard I try I
can never seem to line this shot up like
to get everything perfectly lined up
that's alright it was up guys mkbhd here
so it's the end of 2019 which was a
pretty great year a lot of exciting
stuff happened but I am pretty pumped
for 2020 the start of the new decade yes
it's a new decade I'm sticking with that
and all the stuff that comes with it and
just following up on already great year
so rewinding just a little bit just to
recap you might remember at the
beginning of this past year I said that
the goal for this channel was to make a
hundred high-quality tech videos we got
a 99 the year before would have been
nice to cap triple digits this video for
this calendar year is number 110 and I'm
actually really proud of that I don't
think we were rushing any or we're over
cranking out videos when we didn't need
to inside of that we had full-length
retro tech episodes we had interviews
with Bill Gates and Will Smith and Satya
Nadella we had the smartphone Awards we
had the blind smartphone camera test
we had re uploading a video a thousand
times to see what it would look like a
whole bunch of interesting stuff in
there so 110 videos this year I think
that's a good pace to keep but on top of
that we also started the wave form
podcast that is already one of the top
of all tech podcasts on earth according
to Apple podcasts so shameless plug but
I'll link that below and I'm really
proud of that and I think well I know
that the podcast is gonna be even bigger
and better because of our plans for 2020
so the waveform podcast and the channel
are now like that and in case anyone was
curious in the Ultimate Frisbee world
pride of New York had a pretty good
season we won pro championships this
summer and we made it to the semi-finals
of nationals and the pro team New York
Empire went 15 and OH making it to the
Final Four
then beating Indianapolis in the semis
and beating Dallas in the finals to cap
off an undefeated season and to win New
York's first
[ __ ] championship so on to the next
decade of course is a bunch of tech to
look forward to I'm gonna start off off
the bat with foldables this is gonna be
the year for foldables to better define
themselves as a category you know right
now every foldable that comes out sort
of gets they all get compared to each
other even though they're not quite the
same thing sort of the same way every
new electric car that comes out gets
compared to Tesla just because
we have a default right now 2020 is
exciting we already have that Motorola
RAZR that we've already seen coming out
in early 2020 assuming nothing goes
wrong that's your vertical folding
clamshell design that's super
reminiscent of the razor we had in years
past and now we also have these rumors
and renders of a clamshell samsung
galaxy fold and this sort of feels like
it would be a direct competitor to the
razor but Samsung would also be doing it
their own way potentially with different
materials different high-end specs and
cameras and potentially at a very
different price and then there could
also be a new way made X there could
also be a new Escobar folding phone but
the point I'm making is price
competition is gonna be real now in
folding phones we get past the first gen
wherever and sort of figuring it out and
now we actually have price competition
to see you know do you want to buy a
$2,000 folding phone or an $850 folding
phone or a $3,000 folding phone so
that'll be interesting to see and then
something that I just want to see
everyone take part of is high refresh
rate all the things see this was already
a theme of 2019 I do recall some people
having their feathers ruffled by the 1
plus 7 Pro winning the MVP of my
smartphone Awards spoiler alert but
there really was a divide this year
between high refresh rate in smartphones
and those that stuck at 60 Hertz for at
least one more year last year so 2020 is
the year I'm hoping Samsung flagships
motor-oil flagships Apple flagships I
hope everyone's best smartphone this
year has at least a 90 Hertz display
we're expecting some to be 120 but high
refresh rate all the things and then
we'll also see that sort of trickled
down in price - we're getting mid-range
phones that have 98 screens so then that
leads me to pixel for a not pixel 5 I'm
sure that'll still be a really
interesting phone in 2020 also with
pixel for a is the one that I and a lot
of people are looking forward to so
pixel 3 I came out at Google i/o so
that's May or June so that's around one
will expect to see the follow-up this
year and we're already seeing renders of
it based on speculation and leaks and
basically the exciting thing is Google
actually has some real proof of what
people want in smartphones and they can
see that in their sales numbers so pixel
for a can be that mid-range slash
budgets
with an excellent camera no frills you
know the Google software experience and
software updates a headphone jack and
maybe a trick or two up its sleeve so
with as competitive as mid range and Men
budget phones have gotten in the past
couple years Google having a leg in
there would be really nice but that's a
nice segue to galaxy s 11 which I'm
super ready for it and I think it
wouldn't be a stretch to right now call
that an early frontrunner for best phone
of next year or at least most hyped
phone of next year there are lots of
renders of galaxy s 11 already - with a
lot of focus on those cameras we're
looking at a potential five camera setup
on the back of galaxy s 11 but not just
that we could also see the high refresh
rate 120 Hertz AM OLED display could
have a bigger five thousand milliamp
hour battery the latest and greatest in
silicon that snapdragon 865 I would
agree with a lot of people that the
galaxy s 10 and s 10 plus from this year
were some of the biggest snubs of the
year in the smartphone Awards because
they sort of fly under the radar coming
out earlier in the year and the note
comes out after it but galaxy s 11 and s
11 plus are looking super good and of
course s11 II is also supposed to come
out around that same time probably on
the same launch day but we're looking
forward to s 11 and then one more
smartphone and you've got to see this
coming the iPhone I guess this will be
11 s or 12 I never know what they're
gonna call it but the new iPhone the
20/20 iPhone the flagship and it's funny
I've been on this train for a while
we're also expecting to see an iPhone se
- essentially we're gonna see something
like an iPhone 8 style body with
upgraded internals so that's of course
less exciting but that's also happening
this year but the new flagship iPhone
has to have a lot going for and it turns
out because of what they've done with
iPhone design you can basically take
everything I said last year about the
iPhone and apply it this year but with
like twice as much confidence the new
iPhone and a lot of this for me is
specifically because of how much I like
the new iPad pro so I'm not so secretly
hoping that the new iPhone has that like
really industrial boxy sort of design
I'm also hoping that maybe this is the
first year that we get 120 Hertz display
in the
I phone just like we have in the iPad
pros I am hoping that maybe we also get
a USB type-c port in the new iPhone if
they're willing to do it on the iPad
maybe they're willing to do in the
iPhone I don't know and then naturally
we've come to expect high-end
performance and iPhones a lot of people
don't know this but the one terabyte
iPad pro has six gigs of RAM maybe we'll
see a high-end terabyte iPhone 11 with
the six gigs of there's all these these
things that I've seen the iPad pro that
I want in the iPhone so yeah so that but
2020 iPhone I really just want new
design high refresh rate USB type-c the
rest for me is kind of a bonus and I
know their cameras are gonna be good
again but yeah 2020 iPhone ok 5g5
I passed on 5g last year as one of those
tech things I was looking forward to
most as it was super early and I
actually have been impressed with how
much 5g has progressed since then and I
don't think it's gonna be at the
forefront again I think there's gonna be
a lot of 5g phones but we actually got
to test 5g this year with
millimeter-wave where we saw its
strengths and we saw some of its
weaknesses and shortcomings and we got
to see low and mid band 5g which had its
own set of benefits 5g isn't expected to
be some instant thing of course it's a
multi-year rollout and each carrier has
a different way of doing that multi-year
rollout but I think keeping an eye on
those low to mid band 5g rollouts is the
most interesting part for most people
they'll still see the crazy tests of
millimeter wave getting a thousand up
and down but keep an eye on that low to
mid band 5g and then okay so camera
stuff I'm gonna take a page out of Dave
2ds book here because I'm excited about
the same thing that he also mentioned
he's excited about in one of his video
I'll link his video below but the red
comodo system it's a new body style for
red cameras some of you know I shoot on
red cameras and I don't talk about
production stuff all that much but there
comodo system is expected to be a much
smaller like softball-sized camera six
case sensor new sensor entirely Canon RF
mount weather sealed they've been
teasing this thing for a couple of
months and we're expecting to see it
come out in early to mid 2020 and
because of its size and expected
versatility I think for me this is going
to be the car video camera this is going
to be the travel camera for me over
things like the Blackmagic
get six K that I was considering getting
that I'll probably wait on now so the
red komodo camera system it's pretty
niche and i know not a lot of people
care about that but i am ready for it
and then to bring it all back to
electric cars as kind of the most
exciting new thing in tech for a lot of
people we got an electric mustang this
year which was pretty sweet to see and
we got an electric porsche we got the
thai can actually coming out and
shipping to people i would love to do
videos on both of those by the way but
you can't talk about electric cars
without at least mentioning tesla and
what they seem to have in the works is a
triple motor plaid drivetrain for Model
S at the end of 2020
and then of course their semi truck is
supposed to come out next year or at
least slowly start being manufactured if
they can figure out manufacturing there
and then Tesla Model Y is expected to
actually be ahead of schedule for
production and we should see the first
model wise shipping the customers in
early 2020 they've been spotted on roads
for a couple of weeks now which is
always a good sign of them testing
prototypes and things like that so model
y seems to be right around the corner
but then the Tesla Roadster 2020 is this
famed
quickest production car ever actually
going to come out when they promised it
would which is during the year 2020 no
there's no actual update on Tesla comm
with any of this information but just
going from Elon tweets which is kind of
what we have to do at this point and I
think actually Franz that Tesla has also
mentioned this on a podcast but the
Roadster seems to be delayed until at
least after the plaid triple motor Model
S which is the end of 2020 so that's
probably a 2021 type of thing and I'm a
little bummed about it yes but I also
never expect Tesla to be on time so as
long as they actually do deliver what
they said they would I'll be really
excited but yeah model why seems to be
actually ahead of schedule and ready to
start hitting the streets in 2020 so
there you have it that's some tech I'm
looking forward to and I'm really ready
for in 2020 some high refresh rates here
some new pixel for a and new iPhone and
Galaxy S 11 here and there I'm just I'm
ready to start this new decade on a high
note
hopefully January at CES is where we
start to see some cool stuff either way
thanks for watching catch in the next
decade
pace